chris sale moments away from making his
2021 debut for the boston red sox to
take on the baltimore orioles chris sale
2021 debut last major league start he
made was two years and one day ago
there it is coming right now
and a pop-up
bowl guards in the left
and sale gets his first man that was a
long wait to get another out for him
well that's got to feel good right there
there's no doubt about it he's got to be
failing i don't care how long you play
how great you are
the adrenaline must be kicking
back door johnson here
swinging in a miss he struck him out
with a slider sweep me
how about that looking back door went
all the way across
first k up
another o2 pitch here it is and he
swings and misses it a high outside
heater he got him sail fans two in the
first inning as he walks off the mound
after his scoreless top of the first
and jorge lopez
so there are the numbers coming off two
of his better starts of the year and
yeah you know it's not about stuff it's
about command can you use your pitches
and he you know he's used the slider a
little bit more used to change up a
little bit more
low guards on deck
and a base set
pass third down the line kiki takes a
wide turn heads on back to second
back to back hits to begin it against
lopez well the bases are loaded and
endeavors trying to make lopez pay here
that one bounces to the backstop and
that will get a run in here comes kiki
and red sox leading one to nothing ready
for another 3-2 pitch here it is swing
there's a drive to high and deep to
right center field this one is launched
it is long gone way up into the
bleachers with the bullpen split and the
red sox lead at four to nothing raffy
has three home runs in five at bats
against this picture jorge lopez and the
red sox
lead it four nothing
payoff pitch
yes
struck him out
number three for the lefty first pair of
shoes on the season for mr sale nicely
done how do you take this pitch
two doubles and a homer for dalbeck last
night
one hop to thirds to second for one on
to first the orioles turned two man in
scoring position and here's verdugo who
grounded a single down the left field
line his first time up
and that's going to drop down the line
that'll bring in another run
kk in the score red sox leading it five
to nothing here's xander second at bat
in the second inning for the number
three hitter
he stings this one
rolling into the gap nobody out there
it's all the way to the wall
berduga rounds he powers in into
he sets him down
for his fourth k in the book two outs
nobody on orioles trail the red sox six
nothing top of the third
so back to the top of the lineup with
austin hayes payoff pitch
hey swings he drives this one out
towards left field and it starts to tuck
right at the line and fair or foul it's
fair it's a monster home run for austin
hayes and the orioles find life they cut
the lead 6-1 in the third one strike on
mancini who struck out swinging
that ball's hit well deep center field
back back and this one is gone
straight away center back to back jacks
by the orioles and it's a 6-2 game
2-2
and he struck him out caught him looking
94 miles an hour
one two duran swings around at a
fastball up top and he's set down a
strikeout and two away here in the third
sweepage thank you pretty nasty 80 mile
an hour slider
got it in and he struck him out
yes that time 95 yes
his seventh strikeout
trying to have a big day bases loaded
the all-star third baseman 29 homers 88
runs batted in tied for the most in the
big leagues and he goes the other way
for a base hit
kk in he scores and so far a four rbi
day for raphael
it's a second this could be two there's
one on to first and the orioles turn two
and get out of the inning
round ball and a missed there by dalbeck
that'll get into right field
around second
martin on the move and a throw not in
time
so they could be safe at first and third
and the base hit by wins
well i thought that martin was going to
be safe easy at third that throw all the
way in from renfrow he's off tagged him
he's out
how about that i think that's pretty
clear yes
yeah they're showing it for the fans and
they all agree
oh this is not taking long either high
fiving him out there and he's out how
about that that is
that's branch work for the red sox
looking for number eight
on the day
hey that's it
he had him swinging at that last friday
so if he gets mancini you let him walk
off the mound with five innings in the
7-2 lead
pounding ball to short
xander has time he gets him
chris sale coming off the mound
seven to two and here's the hands that's
what i'm talking about
giving him a standing ovation as he
leaves them out after five innings
allowing two runs on six hits with eight
punch-outs
that one's stung headed for the triangle
mckenna on his horse that gets way out
there in the bottom oh here we go
coming around he'll score
durant into third pulls up with a triple
eight to two bobby dolby next
high fly deep to left it's sailing it is
gone bobby d is hot i'm telling you
not only jacked into center down for a
base hit
[ __ ] will score for the fourth time
verdugo sliding into third and the beat
goes on for the red sox bats
11-2 so jd becomes the ninth man to hit
in the inning
drive this one is back back back and
gone
martinez number 22
14-2 red sox
so two away from bobby dalbeck who has
ripped a two-run homer
high deep drive he got a hold of another
one
and that will clear everything his
second home run on the day
a high fly
deep drive rental and see you later
his 21st he can feast on some salad
candy i mean goodness